I'm gonna be cruising around Tokyo and I'm going to show you...
...what I think are 25 of the top things to do when you're in Tokyo.
So, keep watching this video.
Let's explore Tokyo together right now.
I am at the Ameya-Yokocho Market, just next to Ueno station and park.
There is almost everything in this market you can imagine: from cosmetics,..
...I've seen big piles of shoes, jackets, clothes, golf stores, like, army fatigues stores,...
...and also it's very famous for buying snacks so, giant snack stores.
You can pick yourself up some green tea kitkats.
You can spend a few hours here wandering around and exploring, for sure.
We just took a walk through the park...
...and now we are about to enter the Meiji Shinto Shrine.
So, this is one of the most famous places to visit when you're in Tokyo.
Located in the center of Tokyo yet in the midst of a quiet forested area,...
...Meiji Jingu is one of the landmarks...
...and most important religious Shinto monuments in Tokyo.
When I visited, I got lucky to see a wedding ceremony taking place.
I am at the Sumo stadium.
Pretty cool place to visit.
I'm pretty bummed right now that I'm not here during a fight time.
You can come here when it's not fight season.
And, there's a little museum at the stadium.
It's pretty small but there is a bunch of photographs of the different famous sumo wrestlers,...
...as well as little 3D models of basically every kind of winning technique or position.
After going to the museum,...
...no visit to Tokyo's Sumo town would be complete without a proper sumo feast...
...and a dish known as "chankonabe."
This hearty stew tastes absolutely amazing...
...and it will fill your belly with extreme satisfaction.